[Music]
obviously we've all heard johnny depp
has won right hey let's go
back i'm an amber her truther though
actually oh yeah
i think she's i think she's getting
[ __ ] over in this case yeah i'll be
i'll be listening to the appeal if you
ask me
for you good for you
hey look believe all women oh [ __ ]
he said
he said at the same time i wasn't
surprised at all i thought that was
coming i knew that was coming out women
wasn't something we just do for a little
while by the way
you guys just all forgot what did we do
before yeah well we were supposed to
keep doing it
with the shoulder drug i thought that
was only for like two years but yeah
that's what i heard so so so he wins the
case
but the uh real star of the show ends up
being uh one of his lawyers right
camille vasquez everybody she has a
question they were always shipping them
right yeah are they shipping them is
that what's happening they were like
they were getting raw clothes and like
just snickering all the time a lot of
coffee and stuff and he's like oh thank
you
people are shipping them because it
looks like she's his like knight in
shining armor standing up for him and
like his in his like dignity and his
integrity yeah there's a damsel in
distress she got she did have beef with
amber heard she was making her look
foolish bro she was flipping her off in
court dude yeah she was going like that
and [ __ ] but also what did you expect
like someone with a latino wife you
think she
camille was gonna lose to amber's
lawyers
have you ever argued with a latina
before it's it's wrong
it's hard not winning it's hard that was
the best move he could have made for his
like legal defense
i want to see like a latino lawyer and
like a vietnamese lawyer just like going
oh that that court case will be like 10
years they'll probably start scrapping
actually can we do a re-trail with all
viets
oh my god i ever heard the wrong people
she got a bunch of jewish dudes she
should have got some vietnamese oh she
said they would have played dirty dude i
don't think they would have had like the
bandwidth to type all of that out
properly like in the legal proceedings
gotta get a fast one huh oh man
this
i like how they're not really making
better points though i don't
they're not making better better points
just a lot of expletives well with the
[ __ ] that she had like the evidence she
had it was all proven completely wrong
yeah like it was all lies i felt so bad
for her lawyers because they
had nothing to work with they were just
like what do we do with this [ __ ] and
then they just come out looking dumb
yeah that's crazy a public uh trial
where everyone gets to watch pick more
likable lawyers man
dude how do you win it means lawyers how
do you win when like the idea is you get
the girl you get amber on the stand and
it's like did you in fact poo poo on the
bed
like just bringing that up and putting
that in everyone's heads it's already
that imagery it's over
her explanation was like it was a joke
it was a prank
i think that would be
hilarious of a lawyer camille vasquez uh
uh recently was promoted for this trial
she made partner a partner with brown
rudnick yeah because of it yeah i don't
know what that means yeah yeah but when
i watch a lord movie and it's like it's
like
because the uh law firm she was part of
was brown rudnick but now to be like
brown rudnick vasquez i'm guessing is
what they'll change the name too that's
pretty cool
that's name partner i don't know it's
like if this became jka news
jk news dude you guys are all jk news
remember i did the acronym for you guys
right
now jitsukawa or jay kwang for
bart right
it stumbles a little bit
uh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
jkkk news right bring it to the hood
okay but it's
worth taking it you know like we're
taking the hood we're taking the hood
back oh
oh like the hooded
yeah oh making the whole workshop again
yeah
we'll figure it out yeah
yeah yeah that's the kkk
there's a okay you could also say hood
that like neighborhood and then there's
the kkk hood so i gotta explain the joke
to you guys i know we should do let's
launch it and then we'll figure it out
that's what we do around here but make
merch first what the viewers think
happened okay yeah i feel like that much
would hit it
we should do a really big birch bite too
so we have a lot of inventory
like hundreds of thousands we're gonna
be in the whole heavy and then dig
ourselves out we don't want our
customers against the wall to order it
then they can't get it when it's all hot
i know right
we've been having so many shipping
issues from china like why would you
want to do that to yourself
we just gotta order i'm gonna get hella
dixie flags i will get a lot of hoods
though if we placed an order that big
they would go this this has to get out
like they're like somebody from america
is ordering 500 000 kkk shirts
we'll get the shipping through but yeah
you know what's funny is they get kkk
shirts from china do you think they get
tikki uh torches thrown in as like an
additive like they're buying in bulk
yeah
well you know i mean
we um we sent a lot of merch from like
losing teams to like uh poor countries
yeah all right and that that happened
too with the civil war
really so there's a lot of confederate
merch like just everywhere yeah and like
yeah a lot of different countries
army surplus there's old stuff here
they're just like yeah we don't want
them yeah let's
sell it with your flags blankets yeah
koozies
so somewhere out there there's a little
cambodian boy
with the [ __ ]
civil war basket
a confederate hat that's right yeah
fake ray bans with the logos on the side
let's do another kid with a four-peat
laker shirt yeah there's a kid in a pool
and he's got like a he's under like an
inflatable confederate flag
but it stays a flop
when i was at usc there was an
international student who uh like she
was from china she's wearing this cool
like military jacket i don't think she
knew what any of the patches were she
had a confederate flag
she was a racist and she was in like
she was just like walking around campus
wrapping a confederate flag but i don't
think she knew what it meant
she would always just get like these
weird looks she got some compliments
though like yo that jacket is
it's kind of like sticking it to him in
a little bit right
it's like hey did you know the back of
your jacket says white power why because
confederate real hardcore confederators
wouldn't want to see a chinese person
wearing that [ __ ]
that's pretty good you're kind of
[ __ ] on themselves
it's like you've reduced our flag to
just that
a fashion symbol you don't even know
what it is do you think there was some
amber her johnny depp trial merch that
they would sell on the outside
yeah weren't they doing that dude i
can't wait if it was like the eastern
western conference finals like
head-to-head type stuff
a bunch of kids in africa amber heard
[ __ ] losers
they should do that like instead of like
super bowl championships it's like
supreme court like championship trial
shirts
you know what i mean it was the biggest
court case they could have done every
generation of redone like the roe v wade
merch you don't need this whole year
dude that was a big one but it got kind
of overshadowed by this one that's how
stupid humans are i hope this means
they're gonna start uh televising or
like broadcasting more cases they should
because the one i really wanted to see
was the galen one and that one was
bigger than this [ __ ] yeah for some
reason
this is boring
it was so boring
but i thought it was kind of weird where
none of them none of none of the people
that she you know uh accused were were
were caught for anything
what were you talking about
well if you saw the trial you would know
steve are you part of a team to cover up
this
no no no no i'm just saying i'm just
gonna thank you green's husband i'm just
saying if nick if he thought he he was
kind of suspicious mr nikki green
thank you if gallane
was you know she would she get what she
get convicted of right
sex trafficking right yes
miners yeah
to to who to who
that's all
that's all i'm saying
can you prove that she sexual sex
trafficked to anyone because we don't
know anybody that she sucks there's no
ledger or anything there's no list
that's why they didn't televise the
court [ __ ]
yeah whatever happened well that's why
they didn't release the names of anyone
right because they were like well
because it didn't happen
yeah
exactly
steve is steven's team jeffrey epstein
killed himself i just think we should
listen to all sides i think your team
believe all women devils
that's what it is i do believe women
including colleen maxwell no
doesn't stop guys it doesn't stop at
like oh just because
you do what do you do that could choose
your battles because i'm on this side of
the table i'm with steve i'm telling you
that hey mr believe all women what do
you do when two women are arguing
which one i stay silent yeah
[Applause]
yeah i recuse myself
and i will i would like to appoint a
woman
a female judge yes
pro-choice or pro-life
uh i let the woman answer it for me wow
it has nothing to do with my organ this
guy is pulling up from her that's not
going to do with my organs how do you
define a woman
we'll let a woman decide that's why yeah
let a woman answer that oh yeah it's
like
which woman do you want to point to and
i'm like
oh no oh no it's a slippery slope how do
i oh no i'm trying to pander how do i
pander
you can only pan her so much i've
reached my pendulum
pander malfunction
pander overlord
oh
[Music]
you